wir befinden uns hier in einer erdbeben
situation wir sehen ein zerstörtes haus
und wir wissen dass hier personen
möglicherweise verschüttet sind und wir
wissen auch dass möglicherweise
gefährliche stoffe hier gelagert waren
wo man nicht weiß ob sie ausgetreten
sind etc
zweiter teil den man gesehen hat es der
das stromversorgung unterbrochen wurde
und es jetzt die aufgabe ist die
hochspannungsleitungen sozusagen wieder
herzustellen
ich glaube dass wir neben einer generell
und guten zusammenarbeit das
österreichische bundesheer unverzichtbar
ist und ich bin sehr stolz dass wir
immer gemeinsam schulter an schulter und
leider passieren wird immer wieder
katastrophen gemeinsam für die
österreicherinnen und österreicher
arbeiten dürfen